[Music]
here's your money briefing for Monday
April 3rd I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
I think a large influx of cash be it
from a job or even winning the lottery
would boost the strength of a marriage
but it turns out marriages are often put
to the test by either cash shortfalls or
windfalls wsj personal finance reporter
Julia Carpenter looked into new research
on the matter and she joins me now hey
Julia thanks for being with us thank you
for having me so Julia I guess there's
no way around it like they say for
richer or poorer money plays a
significant role in almost any
relationship money tests a relationship
so these are things that present
challenges when they sort of rock the
status quo both a financial setback and
a windfall setbacks can test the
strength of the marriage because when
one partner loses a job or makes a bad
investment or loses an income stream
then the couple then has to decide how
is this going to affect us and similarly
a financial windfall an inheritance a
payout or in the case of some research I
was looking at a lottery win does the
same same thing you know it sort of
rocks the relationship because it's
challenging the status quo okay but
losing money is more challenging to
handle than adding money to your
finances right yes I mean behavioral
economists have found that thinking of
losing money we we have a stronger
emotional effect to that that's true for
everybody than gaining a similar amount
we don't have as strong of an emotional
reaction to that but when it comes to
relationships the research that I've
looked at suggests that huge financial
moves in either direction can shake
couples in much the same way because in
both cases they are exposing weaknesses
in the marriage or sensitive spots in
the marriage that otherwise might have
been overlooked or ignored weaknesses in
the marriage even involving an influx of
cash this is so in a study conducted in
Sweden I was talking to researchers who
had been tracking lottery winners they
looked at them 10 years after they won
the equivalent of a hundred thousand
dollars and the study compared how
single and married winners adjusted to
this and how many of them formed new
relationships and families and how many
of them ended up dissolving their
existing relationships or filing for
divorce and in both cases the winners
households stood to benefit from winning
this a hundred thousand dollars but as
it turns out the person holding the
winning ticket so the man or the woman
in a heterosexual relationship really
affected what happened to the marriage
and what these researchers found is that
in the long run if you were a man who
won the winning ticket you saw reduced
divorce risk and higher fertility so
that means you had a stable marriage and
family formation but in the short term
So within two years of winning this
ticket women their short-term divorce
risk went up especially for low and some
women and those who earned less than
their husbands yeah let's talk more
about that how does a family's income
fit into the equation here with changes
in economic circumstances in either
direction
so we know already from pre-existing
research that wealthier couples have
lower divorce risk and people
experiencing income changes when they
hold less than forty thousand dollars in
net worth as a household they're much
more sensitive to this they are much
more likely to divorce should their net
worth drop or in the case of this
Lottery research should their net worth
increase as a result of this lottery win
so how can couples successfully navigate
significant financial changes in their
marriages and avoid divorce
Cattlemen she is a couples therapist and
she tells clients to embrace flow that's
the ability to adapt to change with one
another to sort of uplift one another's
skills when you're realizing who has the
strength and who is the strong person in
this and in lieu of just deciding okay
you're in charge of this in terms of the
mental and physical household duties
Marina Edelman says that she encourages
couples to instead Embrace this flow you
know the shifting nature of schedules
and responsibilities so when you have
something like this income struck in
either direction if that upends that
previous order and she says the marriage
embracing flow is better able to sort of
absorb this shock and keep moving keep
growing stay together now we've talked
on the show before about how people
trying to repair their finances and
trying to smooth things out might enlist
a financial advisor how about doing that
you know an advisor could help draft a
revised budget for the couple in case of
they have this set a new fund or they
have less income but it doesn't solve
the problem at the heart of the
miscommunication I was speaking with
Adam Cole he is a financial therapist
and he tells people you can have the
greatest plan in the world but if you
don't feel like you're working as a team
then you're taking one step forward even
as you take two steps back all right
that's Wall Street Journal personal
finance reporter Julia Carpenter Julia
thanks so much for being with us thank
you for having me and that's your money
briefing I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
[Music]
thank you